So let's look a little closer at d and d'.
Well, to go up, it needs to go up the high h and again the high h down, so that's just 2h.
That's not we know about the distance in the green frame. There's a term on this clock t.
Let's say we haven't measured the time it takes to go from the bottom to the top.
Well, then I know that this distance is just equal to velocity times time.
Remember that's an equation we can always use when something is moving at constant speed
and we believe that this light is moving at constant speed.
That needs to go bottom to top the ct and to go top back to bottom is also ct,
which means the total distance traveled is 2 ct.
I know this is a lot of math but bear with me because it's about to get pretty interesting.
Now, let's look at the prime frame. In the prime frame, we have this right triangle.
Now, I'm going to tell you that one of these three sides of this triangle where it's length must be ct'
because we're talking about the prime frame.
So I want you to tell me which of these three sides has a length of ct'.